OK so we had a request line that looks something like
this. It is followed by a number of headers. Headers have
this format, Name: space value. Let's add some headers. When you
make a request, all of this is sent at once, the request
line followed by a number of headers. These aren't the only
headers that are sent but these are some of the more popular
ones. The first one is called Host, and this is from
the URL. This is the host part of the URL. It's required
in HTTP/1.1. It's not strictly required in 1.0. But why
is this useful? We're already connecting to the machine. So
why do we need to say what the host is again? It would be like if you came up to
me and said, Steve, what is your name? Obviously, you
already know my name. So why are you asking? Well,
it's because web servers may have multiple names. One, one
machine, one web server, can host the website for many websites.
For example, with udacity.com, which is hosted on
Google's app engine, each of those machines host many
websites. So, we need to say which website we're
requesting a document for. The next header, this one
is called User-Agent. This describes basically what, who
is making the request. This is generally your browser.
Your browser put its name in there and there's
also some, some version info and things like that.
And this is really helpful for the servers so
they know what type of machine is making a request.